ollie you had mentioned in season four
you said it wasn't included that you and
half had been doing ivf right so why
wasn't that included yeah i didn't
really think about including it just
because even when i did go on to have
kids like i'm always the one who doesn't
want to say tell anybody i'm pregnant
until after like the three-month mark
like i just want to be safe like i
didn't want all that scrutiny on
something that may or may not work i
mean obviously looking back i'm so glad
it didn't work because i went on to like
have the kids of my dreams and
everything but yeah it was wild looking
back
i also did egg retrieval while we were
at the mansion and they didn't i i
wanted i advocated for them to show it
because i thought it was a really
important message to send and they
refused to film it and said that it
showed me planning for a life outside of
the mansion and that's not something
they wanted on the show that's powerful
we don't want you to show that you could
have a life outside of these walls
without half a life without have
hey i'm holly i am one of them one of
the girlfriends it's crazy it's like
it's like dream come true so that first
season you all didn't even have a
contract no we didn't have a contract
till the last season until the last
season you did it yeah we just signed
releases that's it
wow
how do you feel about that now
it's insane i just feel like it's not
industry standard for a reality show
especially when you have three main
characters of a show it was just weird
because we were kind of treated like
children in a way like you guys live
here so you're just gonna do this show
because it's what i want and you know we
weren't paid for the first half of the
first season for all the episodes they
ordered and we weren't put under a
regular contract what would you go back
and tell
yourselves then about how to approach
the show and what to do differently um
definitely to stand up for myself and
advocate for myself more i'd been in
that relationship for four years and as
the you know being half's like main
girlfriend it was like really heavy and
i'd kind of been conditioned not to ask
for anything and i know bridget and
kendra were
asking why are we not getting paid and i
wish i would have stood up for myself
more earlier i did at one point i
eventually talked to have secretary mary
and said look you know i'm spending
money on like outfits for the show and
like things we're doing like activities
we're doing so i'm spending money to do
the show and then she was like okay
that's not right let's get you guys paid
but like she was the one who came
through
for that well kendra and i definitely
were asking about things like that the
contract getting paid like why are we
just doing this and they basically told
us we know where the door is if we
didn't want to do it that there would be
a million girls that wanted to be in our
shoes yeah they said you're replaceable
so you can't ask for anything so mary
advocated for you
i have to ask how does that make you
feel about hef because do you wish he'd
advocated for you to get paid to get
taken care of by the show are you
resentful of that i mean that would just
be the tip of the iceberg of my
resentment
i just i just i can't believe it like i
don't think the network was necessarily
aware like what was going on as far as
how we were being handled they just saw
us as like being in heft's bubble but
between hef and the executive producer
like they should have known i just feel
like it was coming more from the
executive producer making those kinds of
decisions
i didn't really blame it on half at the
time i guess now that you bring it up
it's possible that maybe he held some of
the blame too but i mean we weren't even
given credits on the show like if you
watch the credits our names never even
come up except for just when we're
interviewed when you say the tip of the
iceberg of the resentment
what's underneath the surface i just
didn't see a lot of things when i was in
a relationship with hef i always wanted
to see him as this amazing person so if
he was ever like instigating drama
between the girls i never saw it i just
blamed it on other girls
you know and
by the time i finally saw that and broke
it off with him it's just it's a lot to
unpack you know you have somebody's back
and want to believe the good things they
say to you for seven years and you end
up feeling betrayed when you look back
and you know realize that that person
never had your back and never cared and
just kind of got a kick out of you not
getting along with other girls or having
a hard time and it's rough i don't think
not to interrupt you but i feel like he
did care
no way
he saw how miserable i was i think he
cared in a narcissistic way like oh my
god she'll hang out with me and watch
old movies i can keep this girl around
but i was just going through so much
you know mental health turmoil that i
confided in in him and he just didn't
care like he just
loved the drama he loved being fought
over
we are here to talk to you about our
show the girls next door and i'm nervous
are you
i'm a little bit nervous too i'm nervous
to re-watch the episodes not so much to
talk about it what were your first
reactions to re-watching that series
premiere horrified i'm a zombie in it
first of all
well it's funny because holly started
re-watching them a while ago because she
was doing these youtube things and she
told me when she asked me if i wanted to
do the podcast i was like yeah sure i
have all these positive memories of it
and
so then she was like okay i just want to
warn you though episode one two and
three are a little um rough rough and
then once you get past that it gets
better and i was like okay and i thought
she just kind of meant getting into it
again and like watching yourself on tv
again but episode one two and three i
was horrified what is horrifying about
it what don't you like about the way you
were made to look and we did develop
like a close friendship with the
executive producer and but then when i
go back and i look at it now and i see
things i didn't notice before i'm like
oh really he did that to me so it's kind
of a feeling of betrayal inside as well
definitely i just feel like i was edited
to look like i have absolutely
no
personality or interests
and it's just i mean it changes over the
five seasons we get into all the layers
of reality tv that's the whole
conversation i'm seeing now what you're
saying because again i just watched it
and they show you going to school they
show kendra going to massage therapy
school and then they show you and this
line you say stuck out to me like if i
could get married and have kids tomorrow
i totally would this is it for me this
is where i am and this is where i'm
going to stay how did you feel watching
that moment well that was true for me at
the time so that was fine but also they
show what kendra and bridget are doing
but i was in school for real estate
investment at the time but they don't
mention that at all like you can see the
books on the side of my bed you can see
me in bed studying but they never
mention it and i just feel like i was
kind of done dirty with that
what about watching the show back does
make you happy or nostalgic what are
those positive things seeing all the
pets because this was 15 years ago so
sadly like none of the dogs and cats are
around anymore because it was so long
ago and you have to steal your
yeah and like when i see myself holding
one of my dogs on tv like it's visceral
like i can remember what that feels like
again so i love that and there were a
lot of fun memories with the three of us
doing things that were new to us and fun
opportunities so even though there was
drama like i have more positive memories
with all three girls or the two other
girls then i have negative yeah you
can't deny there was a lot of fun
opportunities and amazing things that we
got to do so it's not all there's it's
not all negative the way you all were
portrayed you see
you talking about like
kendra getting to do more than you
getting to do other things in that first
episode i was having a hard time
understanding that what was that
difference of kendra being treated
differently than you two were i think
any time in that group when someone was
the new girl they got treated with a lot
more leniency because when i was new to
the group you know i was the one he put
on the pedestal and compared all the
other girls to and tried to make them
feel bad because they weren't doing what
i was doing and if i had a request i got
it because when you're new you don't
have anything sunken and invested into
that relationship have you ever talked
about that with kendra asked her
about that the differences i have not
and she's welcome to come on the show if
she wants to talk about it we'd love to
hear it
how do you feel about that different
treatment you know what i have never
talked to her about it and not because i
wouldn't but for me it's something i
thought is this just in my head like is
it just because it's just me and i'm
thinking i'm i'm it's not fair to me but
now that i'm rewatching and i'm like
no it's not just me it's this is clear
as day well where do you stand with
kendra you just said she'd be welcome to
come on the show yeah i don't talk to
her but she's welcome to come on the
show like i don't
yeah have any problems
i maintained a slight relationship with
her i did an episode on her show one
time i
will text her every once in a while if i
need something or
have a question for her but it's not
like we go to lunch or anything yeah
did you fall in love with her at any
point
i think i definitely thought i was in
love with hef but it was very stockholm
syndrome
very stockholm syndrome i do have to ask
about the playboy docu-series we saw you
both in it a little bit kendra decided
not to do it how do you feel about that
now that the series has come out and the
reaction to it has been out there
well you haven't seen it i have not seen
it no i watched every episode except
episode two that i'm in because i just
did not want to watch myself talk about
my trauma and every episode i watched i
would have nightmares that night
it was crazy when i was first asked to
do the documentary i didn't want to do
it i heard that it was going to be kind
of a negative portrayal and my like i
said my experiences are positive
and i told them i didn't think that my
story fit their narrative and they were
really pushing for me to do it
like to the point where i was crying on
the phone with them i don't want to do
this
and then between my agent and other
people they felt like i should do it and
then again i feel like my story didn't
fit their narrative so they only cut
down my interview how much do you think
the show affected
your experiences at the mansion the
mansion for those years the show made it
so much better i say like i mean i might
have my things to say about the show and
the editing here and there like trust me
there's a lot but i always say like the
show saved my life because it
gave us so many opportunities and it
gave us value in hep size because now we
were like assets so he treated i felt
like he treated me a lot better after
the show was established and after he
saw that we had a following and after he
saw that the audience was really
invested in like his and my relationship
and fans would be like oh we want you
guys to get married and then he was like
super into me what a word you just used
though holly you said it made him see
you as assets yeah which if that
someone's your partner for them to see
you as an asset
there's a darkness to that
you know
like for him to say well now i see
you're valuable because you're making
this show work for me
so where does your brain go with that
and how much do you think you're gonna
unpack some of that stuff with the
podcast we're definitely gonna unpack
all that with the podcast but i think at
the time i knew it i knew why he was all
of a sudden so much more interested in
me and making our relationship work
but at the time i was just so grateful
for being treated better i didn't care
the reason i think the mansion was very
cult-like looking back on it
is because we were all kind of gas-lit
and expected to think of hef as like
this really good guy
and you started to feel like oh he's not
what they say in the media he's just a
nice man are you guys glad you did the
docu-series i decided to do it just
because i knew so many other women were
coming forward with their stories and i
know what it feels like to feel like
you're the only one so i wanted to be
supportive of that yeah i wish i didn't
do it um
like i said it didn't i didn't really
meet their narrative and i i'm glad that
my story some of my stories corroborated
some of holly's stories so i'm happy
with that but like i just uh
wish that i didn't do it at all well so
now you're doing the podcast is part of
the podcast
you wanting to kind of take back your
history and do this and
tell your full experiences that you had
there absolutely you know people always
ask me they're like if you're so
traumatized by why are you still talking
about it but being able to talk about it
on your own platform where you can
really get across what you want to say
and go over all the nuances and the
things that might seem contradictory is
really satisfying for me i've never
really talked about it on any kind of
show and so this is my first time really
kind of opening up about it
[Music]
you